[NOISE] This is the Earth.
Okay, lesson over.
Just kidding.
You're going to render your own
map in your site in just a moment.
Google Maps are made up of lots
of different types of data.
Imagery, road networks,
points of interest, more things.
You'll use pieces and
combinations of that data,
to build a user experience
that has value.
When you render a map, you can control
what type of information you get.
One of the most basic things you can
control when you render your map,
is the map type.
We have four preconfigured map types.
You're probably most
familiar with the road map,
map type which you've seen as
the default in Google Maps.
We also have satellite if you
want real images of the world, or
hybrid in which we overlay features such
as roads on top of satellite imagery.
And finally, we have terrain,
which emphasises shaded relief and
other physical terrain information.
Now that you understand
what you're seeing,
let's load the map into your site.
I'm starting off with
just a basic HTML site.
It’s blank right now.
You can load a Google Map into your
site simply by adding three things into
your code.
The first is a script line into
your HTML to load the API.
This loads the JavaScript definitions
when the page starts loading in
the browser.
We're loading the Java Script here
asynchronously which means that the rest
of the page will render while
the Java Script API loads,
and then our call back function will
execute when the API is done loading.
If you're not immediately
using the API's functionality,
you can put the same instruction
inside a function and
call it only when you plan to use it.
Loading the API asynchronously gives you
more speed as it let's your page load
without having to wait for
the JavaScript.
Maps.Googleapis.com is the endpoint
that we're loading the JavaScript from.
The parameter v=3 indicates
that we're calling
version three of the api which is
the version that we want to use.
Next, you must include the API
key that you just created.
Use the key perimeter and
simply paste in the browser key
that you generated in your project.
Alternatively, you can use the client
ID if you're a Max API Premium Plan
customer.
We’ll learn more about
that later in the course.
The next thing that you need is
a div element in your html body
with the ID of map, easy.
I'm also adding some css to specify
that I want our map to be 100 percent of
the height of the page.
Finally, we'll need
some more JavaScript,
a map variable and an initialized
JavaScript function to load the map.
Something to note, I'm putting all of
this in one file, but you can also
separate out your JavaScript into
a separate file to keep it neat.
This initialize function will contain
everything that will happen after
the page loads, but
before the user interacts with the map.
For now,
its only job is to make a map appear.
We're creating a new map instance here.
And we must specify two things, where in
the HTML to load the map, which is going
to be that map div that we created,
and what part of the world to show.
We have to give it a center and
a zoom value so it knows what imagery
to show and in how much detail.
The center is a latitude and
longitude in the form of what's
called a lat long literal.
We'll use this all the time
throughout the course.
The zoom is just a number.
The higher the number, the more detail.
You can go up to level 21.
All right, you've made a beautiful
dynamic map of your very own.
This map is centered on the lovely
Google office in New York City.
Notice that all classes live
within the google.maps namespace.
We just saw an example of this when we
used the google.maps.map class to create
a map object.
As you learn more about the classes,
you'll see this naming
convention over and over.
Now you try.